hey if you have a moment check out our
online store at anime out Broadcom we
have exclusive designs created by pro
manga artist Kazuma including esken or
praise the Sun meliodas feel the wrath
and for a limited time all transiting
shaggy one-shotting Thanos because yes
that's a thing all the proceeds directly
support more content on this channel so
check it out link in the description
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and this video was
highly requested by many of you guys who
followed the channel and especially
after the seven deadly sins prisoners of
the sky movie came out on Netflix we got
a huge influx of people asking for a
video about this particular character
well you guys know that I take your
requests very seriously without all of
you who watch and support this channel
there would be no channel so here we go
an entire video about the mother of
chaos if you enjoyed the seven deadly
sins content on this channel you can
leave a like to let me know and if
you're new don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell by the way
our weekly anime podcast called rant
cafe is now available wherever you get
your podcasts Spotify iTunes Google Play
and more just search us up rant cafe
anime podcast it is hosted by myself NOx
Taku and Briggs from all the anime and
we feature special guests like lost paws
mystique anoxia teching 101 and many
more you can also find all the episodes
and some bonus material on the rant cafe
YouTube channel and if you want to watch
the podcast live as we record it and
give us feedback in the chat in real
time you can follow us on Twitch
twitch.tv slash anime uproar and
twitch.tv slash rant cafe all of the
links are in the description for your
convenience
finally spoiler alert this video will
contain spoilers from the seven deadly
sins prisoners of the sky movie and it
will also contain some spoilers from the
seven deadly sins manga beyond the anime
believe it or not the movie does appear
to be closely related to some of the
important information that we learned
later on in the manga and I will have to
get into all of that in order to fully
explain everything that we know so far
about the legendary mother of chaos now
I talked about this in a previous video
but I know that there are a lot of
people out there who don't consider
prisoners of the sky to be at all
relevant to the main seven deadly sins
story so I want to take a moment to
explain why I think that the information
we received about the mother of chaos in
the movie is important to the main story
as well
the official Monica for the seven deadly
sins naka
Suzuki put a great deal of effort into
connecting the movie to the main manga
storyline
he created the new movie characters
himself they were not created by some
movie studio or third party writers and
in Chapter 203 of the seven deadly sins
manga the six nights of black were
directly mentioned the Endura of
retribution that appears near the end of
prisoners of the sky was also introduced
in the manga as an acquaintance of
gallant the cover of chapter 277 of the
official manga features salad and a
latte - movie only characters and the
winged sword that the Celestials use in
the movie is actually shown in chapter
274 of the manga we see a young male
wielding what appears to be that very
same winged sword in a flashback so
because of all of these deliberate
connections that were made between the
prisoners of the sky movie and the
official manga I will consider the
information that the movie gave us about
the mother of chaos as potentially
useful even if the timeline of the movie
is a bit off the first thing that we
need to talk about is the great oshiro
according to the legends of the
Celestials who are descendants of the
goddess clan and who inhabit the sky
temple during the previous holy war the
six nights of black and other demons
were about to destroy the temple but a
mythical shining white pig-like creature
appeared and helped the goddess clans
seal the demons away the white pig-like
creature that saved the sky temple was
known as the great oshiro and the
Celestials still pay respect and
celebrate this creature the legend
describes the great oshiro as a shining
white pig and at the very end of the
prisoners of the sky movie we see a
small part of hawks Mama's green skin
peel away to reveal a shining white
surface below which is a pretty obvious
and blatant clue that Hawks mama is
indeed the legendary creature known as
the Great or Shiro also by the way I'm
fully aware that right now we are all
looking at a giant pig's ass I mean yes
I know it's kind of weird but this is my
job I'm an anime youtuber so bear with
me this is important
another thing that we learn at the end
of the movie is the fact that Merlin
says that the great Oshiro is just
another name for the mother of chaos so
who is the mother of chaos in chapters
233 and 234 of the manga or laundy a
member of the vampire clan who was
transformed into a creepy flying eye 12
years earlier by Merlin states that
vampire royalty like him are born from
the mother of chaos we can assume that
when he says vampire royalty or royal
vampires he means vampires who were born
as vampires original vampires if you
will and this differentiates them from
individuals from other clans who were
turned into vampires later on in life so
according to or laundy all the original
vampires ie all the royal vampires were
born from the mother of chaos in Chapter
263 of the manga in the qat corner the
mangaka naka bouzouki was asked is it
possible that races other than the first
five will appear in the future the five
races are of course humans demons
goddesses Giants and fairies Suzuki
responds by saying
apart from the main five there are also
monsters all born from the mother of
chaos so according to this the mother of
chaos gave birth to the vampires and to
all monsters
we know that the vampires were allied
with the demon clan but they are not
demons themselves so it would make sense
for them not to fall into any of the
five main races and are instead simply
considered monsters the same is probably
also true for beast men like Jeeva go as
they are humanoid animals that can take
human form but they are not humans
themselves and they clearly don't belong
to any of the other five main races and
if the mother of chaos is the mother of
all monsters then I would argue that she
must also be the mother of all the
creatures from purgatory this would of
course include both Hawk and wild and
also Arthur's strange pet calf as we
know Hawk appears to have been kidnapped
by the demon
King and sent into the world of the
seven deadly sins from purgatory as a
way for the demon king to spy on Mele
Otis an important piece of evidence that
supports the idea that the mother of
chaos is the mother of all the creatures
from purgatory comes from Arthurian
legend we all know how greatly inspired
the story of the seven deadly sins is by
the legend of King Arthur and Camelot
and in Arthurian legend there is a pig
called hanwen or all Dwight basically a
white pig just like the great oshiro and
according to legend this pig gave birth
to a monstrous cat-like creature called
caf-pow Luke and two other mysterious
creatures as well many of whom were
considered monsters we already know that
Arthur's pet calf is a creature from
purgatory so if we go by Arthurian
legend and if we assume that the great
white pig also known as the great Oshiro
and the mother of chaos gave birth to
calf like the old white pig in Arthurian
legend gave birth to calf Pollock and if
we remember that the mangaka confirmed
that the mother of chaos gave birth to
all the monsters then we can assume that
the mother of chaos also gave birth to
hock and wild so if the prisoners of the
sky story can be trusted and hawks mama
is indeed the mother of chaos then Hawks
mama really is Hawks birth mother and
she is also the birth mother of every
creature from purgatory of all the royal
vampires of the beast man and so on but
now the question is how strong is the
mother of chaos according to Merlin the
mother of chaos is said to have
contained so much darkness that she was
feared by the demon clan while at the
same time she possessed so much light
that she was revered by the goddess clan
Merlin's tattoo itself looks a lot like
Hawkes mamas
so it is possible that the mother of
chaos is so strong that even Merlin
wanted to pay tribute to her with the
tattoo and even though she is usually
just in the background so far in the
story we have seen Hawks mama do some
incredible things we saw that she was
able to swallow and completely
neutralize Mon speeds Goku encho or
purgatory flame bird attack without
being hurt at all
she is also seen taking out a horde of
lesser demons include
red and gray demons without any problem
and she also took a direct hit from
derriere ease combo star and although
this did knock her over and injure her
temporarily it did not seem to do any
permanent damage finally in the
prisoners of the sky movie hawks mom
swallows a massive blast from the Endura
of retribution and not only that but she
then directs the blast back at the
Indira without suffering any damage
herself keeping in mind that the Endora
is a demon who had a power level of at
least fifty thousand before becoming an
Endora and keeping in mind that an
endurance power level will be far
greater than the original power level of
the demon before he transformed into an
indoor ax it is clear that Hawkes mama
is actually one of the strongest
characters in the seven deadly sins but
exactly how strong is she there is no
way to know for sure right now we don't
have an exact power level for her and
what we've seen on her power has been
very limited however I think that her
true strength will ultimately depend on
what type of character she ends up being
what exactly is the mother of chaos
clearly she has immense hidden powers
and she is capable of giving birth to
some pretty powerful creatures including
Wildcat and a vampire king is wrath and
of course she gave birth to the great Oh
pink the strongest creature of them all
second only to the mighty Lord to ego so
far we have been told that the demon
king and the supreme deity are the
strongest creatures in existence and
they are of course immensely powerful
they are the rulers of their respective
clans their children are extremely
strong and they are able to create
incredible magical abilities like the
graces and the commandments so if the
mother of chaos had so much darkness
that she was feared by the demon clan
and at the same time so much light that
she was revered by the goddess clan what
exactly does this mean why does the
mother of chaos contain both light and
darkness at the same time and does the
fact that the demons feared her and the
goddesses revered her mean that she is
actually stronger than the demon king
and the supreme deity there is of course
no evidence that she
but it all depends on what role the
mother of Kaos plays in the world of the
seven deadly sins there are many
different possible scenarios she could
be just a very strong creature from
purgatory that somehow ended up in
Britannia or she could be more than just
an ordinary creature she could be
something like a primordial deity in
Greek mythology the primordial deities
in Greek mythology are the first gods
and goddesses born from the void of
chaos and there's that keyword again
chaos chaos in this case means the void
that existed before the physical world
was created and took the shape that it
has now so in Greek mythology the
primordial deities came first and then
they gave birth to the Titans and other
creatures and the Titans gave birth to
the gods of Olympus and of course
eventually the gods of Olympus overthrew
the Titans and became the rulers of
heaven and earth in Greek mythology
darkness was born out of chaos and light
was then in turn born out of darkness so
if Greek mythology is any indication the
mother of chaos might actually be a
deity that is older than all the races
and clans and older than both the demon
king and the supreme deity if we
consider the idea that both darkness and
light were born out of chaos in Greek
mythology we could even ask ourselves
whether the mother of chaos may actually
be the mother of all whether she gave
birth not only to the monsters but also
to all the other races including the
demons and the goddesses perhaps at some
point like the Olympian gods did with
the Titans the demon king of the supreme
deity overthrew their creator the mother
of chaos and that is why they now rule
over the demons and the goddesses over
the darkness and the light instead of
the mother of chaos however even if we
assume that the mother of chaos is the
oldest creature and the mother of all
the other races this doesn't necessarily
mean that she is the strongest after all
the Olympian gods in Greek mythology
were able to overthrow the Titans even
though the Titans created them the true
extent of the mother of chaos as power
can't be determined until we see her in
action a lot more instead of just in the
back
it is totally possible that the manga
Kanaka bouzouki always meant to keep
hawks mama in the background as an
interesting and mysterious side
character so we could see the whole
story come to an end before learning the
full truth about the mother of chaos
that way the manga cut just leaves it up
to the audience to have their own fun
theorizing about the mother of chaos
however it is also possible that the
manga car has some big plans for the
mother of chaos and that she will
eventually play a major role in the
climax of the story the only way to know
for sure is to keep reading the manga
and to keep watching the anime and I
definitely plan to do exactly that I
mean the manga is amazing right now and
I've been just devouring it every week
so if you're still wondering if you
should bother reading the seven deadly
sins manga I highly recommend it and
don't forget to let me know what you
guys think how strong is the mother of
chaos and what is her true origin story
is she the oldest being in the world is
she just a powerful creature from
purgatory or is she something else
entirely let me know down in the
comments if you enjoy the seven deadly
sins content on this channel you can
leave a like to let me know if you are
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification
valve feel free to hit us up on Twitter
and Instagram at anime uproar and give
us suggestions about future videos and
of course don't forget to check out the
rank of a podcast now available wherever
you get your podcasts all the links are
in the description as always thank you
guys so much for watching thank you for
requesting this video and until next
time see us space cowboys
[Music]
you